Let's talk about quick measures.
Quick measures are the next level of built-in calculations that you can
apply to get the calculations you need specifically for aggregatable columns.
They're like the more mature older sisters of the implicit DAX.
Like implicit measures, they don't require you to write DAX.
They are a really handy subset of calculations,
like the ones you see on the right hand,
right here from my screenshot and they're meant
to be high-use general-purpose calculations.
That said, you're not likely to be an escape by without using any DAX at all with them.
But I like that you can use them to learn new DAX calculations.
If you start off using a quick measure,
it does make it easier for you to learn DAX that's new to you,
and you can build on top of them to customize the DAX that
you build off of them to your specific needs.
I never got into the habit of using them since they were
introduced after I started working with Power BI and DAX,
but I'm a little envious that you're getting to start
your Power BI adventure with these quick measures as a starting point.
Let's explore them together.
Back in Power BI,
we have everything just where we left it off with the implicit measures.
Let's start by right-clicking and selecting "New quick measure".
We'll start by just getting a little familiar with our options.
Here we are in quick measures,
and if we go through,
it groups them by aggregate per category,
filtering by specific values or percentages, and time intelligence,
which I have to say to me,
is the most useful if you wanted to see a month over month change.
But of course, running totals with filters and
additional mathematical operations are additionally useful as well.
Let's start with something straightforward.
How about a year-to-date total?
We're going to choose our base value, should be sum,
and instead of price each,
I'm going to go to my Sales Transactions and I'm going to choose amount instead.
Then we need to add a date right here.
We have one of those from our date table.
As you see here at the top,
similar to what we saw before with the M-Code,
where the user interface would develop M-Code for us,
we have this little section where we can see
the specific logic that's been applied on our behalf by Power BI for DAX,
again, data analytics expressions.
If we wanted this to be named something different,
we can freely do so.
Test, DAX, year to date,
whatever you need it to be.
If you look at this,
it is creating slightly more advanced DAX than you might have interacted with before.
Supplying the sum, total year to date by date, date.
I'd really encourage you to explore this further,
it can be a lot of fun to play with these.
You can always just like we showed you just now with the test DAX year to date,
adjusting the name, you can go into this and make further adjustments
to make these quick measures meet your specific needs.
Let's talk about different filters for different datatypes.
Filter options that you have whether you're developing
them on the filter pane specifically for a specific visual,
or if you're putting them into a DAX formula,
are essentially determined by the datatype irrespective of what that filter context is.
Practically speaking, this means that you may not
always be able to filter the way you would expect to be able to,
depending on whether the data is type date,
text string, or number.
Let's start with dates.
Dates give you the option to filter between certain dates,
before or after certain dates,
to manually select specific dates,
or to filter for relative dates.
This could be really handy if you say,
wanted to filter a report,
so it just shows the current year,
the past year, or a future one.
However, there are some limitations when you're trying
to use a date component in a filter context.
An example that I've run into before is when you
have a month that's stored as a whole number.
This'll let you filter using the number context,
but it won't give you option for relative dates,
say if you wanted to be looking at the same month last year.
It's not a big deal if you run into this
because you can simply use the date field instead,
but it is important to know this distinction so that
you're not stuck when you're working through your filter options.
With text strings, you can filter based on whether
a field contains or does not contain certain information.
In a basic sense,
you have the option to simply select all or choose specific fields from a drop-down list,
but with advanced, you're using contains,
does not contain, is blank,
or is not blank.
Then with numbers, you're working with less than,
greater than, is, is not.
This gives you a lot of options to be able to group
things based on the number contexts and based on ranges of numbers.
But if you wanted to filter with say, StartsWith,
which is a text string option,
you will have to approach it differently using a range instead.
The converse is also true.
If you have a value that appears to be a number but it's stored as a text string,
it will allow you to filter for the first value, for example, six,
but not for a range of values which might be preferable depending on your situation.
Here we are back in our reporting view in Power BI.
Let's take a look at some filters and see how they work in context.
If we go back to the filters on this visual,
we can start with State,
which is a text string.
We've got our basic filtering with this drop-down list.
Say we only want to see individuals in California from our customer data list.
I've selected California only,
and it's given me the list just for the State of California.
But let's say that rather than requiring
a selection using just clicking through the list here,
we can use advanced filtering instead if we want to have a more nuanced filter in place.
Instead of is Alabama,
which is pretty similar to the basic filtering
where we would just use is Alabama here with a single click.
With advanced filtering, we can use contains.
If we wanted to grab both Dakotas,
which I'm not sure if they're in this list,
but say we did,
we could say contains Dakota,
and we can hit "Apply filter" to determine indeed there is no Dakota.
Or show items where the value is Dakota or California.
We've got our list of California options back.
You can also choose the top end.
Show items with the top or bottom by the data fields,
so top or bottom say, by amount.
Top 1 by
amount, "Apply filter".
We've got Texas as our top 1 state.
Let's play with some other stuff now.
I don't know if you caught that.
But just to show you, again,
if I go back to basic filtering and I just select one of these,
I can go to "Clear filter" to return it to the default which is select all.
If we use zip code,
which we can check right now and see how it's being treated as a number.
Zip code is going to give us the option of choosing less than,
greater than, is, is not.
We could choose is greater than
29,000 and less than
or equal to 80,000,
"Apply filter", and that will give us a range in the middle.
But we may decide that that's not necessarily practical and we could use is, is not, etc.
Then finally, when we talk about amount,
which is another number option,
you'll be applying similar logic here.
What if we wanted to look at date instead?
Well, this is already showing us a list of
options based on things that we've already selected.
But just because the filter pane automatically
applies the information that's pulled into our visualizations for these values,
doesn't mean that our filter pane is
limited by the ones that automatically populated here.
We can go ahead and grab year, for example,
and if we put it in this Add data fields here,
it will populate for us.
We can use advanced filtering since it's being treated as a number here.
We could say is greater than 2018 and it will filter our dataset based on 2018,
this was 3.3 million, now it's 754,000,
meaning that 754,000 and change sales occurred after 2018.
If we wanted to use the date dimension, we'd grab date,
date, and pull it in as a data field.
There we go. We've pulled in date, date,
it's set to is all and it's giving us basic relative date,
relative time, and advanced.
Advanced would give us on or after, on or before,
is or is not blank,
including for time if that's important for
your dataset and it also gives you relative date.
Show items when the value is in the last 365 days,
for example, including today,
apply the filter, and this would show us everything in
the past year using this specific parameter.
As you can see, as a recording,
we're here on 2/23 and it's pulling in data for this 365-day range.